good morning again everyone my name is
barbara griffin this is the new
hampshire house special committee on
redistricting today is september 30th
and so we know who's here and how we go
forward i'm going to ask the clerk
thank you madam chairman
representative bergeron president
representative barry here
representative simpson for
representative griffin president
representative lynn
here
representative mcdonald is present
representative mcguire here
representative alexander for
representative piedra here
representative marjorie smith
representative steven smith here
representative turcotte
representative weber here
representative wilhelm here
15 in attendance madam chairman thank
you
um
sure
representative weber thank you madam
chair as a preliminary matter i just
want to note that we were told that all
safety precautions were being taken when
we meet in this building and that
included
rooms scheduled so that we could do
appropriate distancing yet here we all
are still sitting
very much too close to each other and i
would hope that at future meetings
the room arrangement would reflect a
more appropriate disposition
thank you thank you for your comment
representative weber the handy thing
about our name plates is that they can
move
um so can members so if someone feels
that if they're not sitting in an
appropriate place feel
free to move your name plate to a
different spot on the table the mics
look like they have plenty of cord
to be moved around to accommodate your
personal request
which we're always happy to try and meet
the first thing on the agenda is i'm
looking for any comments from members on
how it's going with the program we
passed out a thumb drive with a program
that had
two different
programs on it so to speak and i used
the wrong terminology with computer
things for house districts and
congressional districts
i know some of us have spent some very
frustrating evenings working on it and i
just wanted to sort of get some feedback
on how people are doing because at some
point we need to start talking about
actual maps representative mcguire did i
see your hand
yes madam chair i've been working mostly
on the house districts
and specifically in merrimack county
uh the the program works very nicely but
with the
concord wards
varying by a rep and a hat
by about fifteen hundred people
i can't do come up with a complete map
because
concord
cannot be isolated from the rest of the
county
franklin they're probably glad to hear
that
yes well
they would they're part of the county
we've got it got to deal with it
there are sections of the of my map that
i'm quite happy with there are others
that i am not and i really need concord
in order to to balance it
i
was on
it's a lit i i have a hard time telling
whether these buttons are down or up or
what the schematic is but is that on
hearing no
okay
okay well i think this meeting is going
to be fraught with is that sound
yes now i can think a little sorry about
that so i'll repeat i've been working on
the county maps
and
particularly merrimack county
and i can't get very far without having
proper awards in concord
the county commissioners for merrimack
are exactly 15 reps each so i've got two
different plans that i'm happy with for
county commissioners
in merrimack and i've been working on
from grafton county
it's easy enough to get small compact
districts
it is very difficult to give each
town its own rep because of all the tiny
towns that are
around the mall and maintaining the
variances
thank you for sharing your experience
with trying to work on the program does
anybody else have anything
representative weber i'll just state
that i don't have anything to add yet
because i have as yet
to buy the piece of equipment that will
allow the thumb drive to connect to my
computer
as we've only had three of the listening
sessions i will i will be working on
that
okay i also have just had a further
message that there is still no sound for
those who are trying to view all right
is uh somebody from house
watching that somebody is getting a text
that there is no sound
um
can
somebody christina dyer from legislative
the legislative office says that the
sound is working
there's something in every meeting when
there are elect electronics involved as
to what works and what doesn't work it's
somewhat astounding i know that there
was someone outside in the hall from
tech services
a few minutes ago so i'm presuming it
started all right
so i don't know what's happened in the
meantime
we're going to pause for a minute until
we get straightened out on the sound
given that we are live streaming this
this is also being
recorded
so
we
sound is up and running i suspect some
of this has to do with member volume and
how close the microphone is to us
there's a difference between
amplification and recording and we need
to be mindful of it and i apologize
representative weber thank you for
giving us that update
i do know that i have had a
representative tell me that this is not
an exercise you want to do a half an
hour before you're going to bed because
it just gets you completely
riled up
anybody else representative bergeron oh
thank you madam chair i would just note
that the software the the program that
was developed 10 years ago isn't
compatible with apple so those of us
that have apple computers are having a
bear of a time making it work i don't
know if
i t could convert it to an apple
friendly program or not
but i would welcome that if it can be
done
the other thing that
perhaps we can ask it about if somebody
wants to take the program and um take it
from a thumb drive to put it on a dvr or
something like that that their computer
might read i'm sure we can provide that
service also
anybody else on the actual mapping
thank you um
representative mcguire repre reference
county commissioners we're sort of
focused on the house because that is who
we are right here but county
commissioners will need to be done in
every county
that program has been done my apologies
we didn't have thumb drives
or perhaps other drives available for
everybody
but we will get that to you so that you
can work on that piece
every county has districts four county
commissioners except strat stratford is
that correct representative turcotte
that is correct okay
um so
stratford is currently at large
everybody else has districts so that is
going to be a slightly different
formulation for you to work on and we'll
get that to you
the next thing on the agenda is
something that was brought to my
attention
by perusal of lsrs
legislative service requests for
2022 have been filed
and if you look at them you will note
that there is one for a constitutional
amendment dealing with the number of
representatives and the number of
senators
and it occurred to me that while we had
looked at the constitutional
requirements for redistricting and voted
on it such as county lines we had not
actually discussed the number of
representatives which by constitution
can be 375 to 400.
so
with that in mind
i asked
representative
allocation previously that we had looked
at and adopted in regards to county
numbers to take a look at what would
happen if we varied the number of reps
the committee members received and this
will go online
a spreadsheet
of what happens with the county
breakouts for representatives if we go
from the 375 to 400 part of the reason
this discussion is
important is because
there is a need to allocate
representatives proportionately
within certain numerical standards and
if you start off
with a formula that already is not
balanced it makes subsequent work to
balance things within
your percentage of deviation
more difficult
which is why
we're seeing sort of some fluctuations
in representatives for county from
2010 to 2020 that are not apparent by
the gross numbers
so
rep representative
barry excuse me for i think i refer to
you as representative ross
representative barry
if you could explain
the sheet that
i can read if it's very close to my face
yes madam chairman thank you
it's very small because there's um
there's 25 permutations
for 10 counties so there's 250 pieces of
data
that you start with when you're looking
at equal or
and i don't say equal but
proportioning by county
so
to kind of walk the committee through
the sheet
the very first we'll call it section of
data that you'll see
which has the county names
the first number you'll see the right of
those county names is their total
population right that's not for debate
um
and then you'll see at the top of that a
a new
row
in bold which has 400 399 398 going down
all the way to 375 and it shows you what
the perfect allocation
would be per county if that number of
representatives was instituted so we
obviously know what 400 is because we've
been doing all of our math based off of
that but it goes all the way down
there and then underneath that you'll
see very similar to the sheet that was
distributed i believe in our our second
meeting maybe our third
where we i've rounded them down
so using perfect rounding right so if
it's 18.49 it goes to 18 if it's 18.51
it goes to 19.
and you can see what that is per county
the one underneath that
is the ones all the the pretty colors
this is how far away they are from zero
um so let's take uh belknap county
in the 400
if we had 400 state representatives they
right so basically what we're doing is
we're chopping off the 18 and we're
saying all right well they're 0.49 off
from zero
conversely if they were high right so
carroll county is high 14.54
you'll see that underneath there they're
at 0.45 right so it's because it's
easier for them to go up than it is for
go to go down right so we're looking at
the difference to zero right whatever
whatever the closest
next whole number is if you will
um
so that's how far they're off so the
reason that they're color coded is
obviously we want to be as close to the
nearest whole number as possible right
because that's the most
even proportional representation
possible obviously there's no perfect
solution
but i wanted to present to the committee
what that looks like so red is bad green
and yellow is in the middle
so um you could see 400 i just want to
um
so
you can see that 400 is not ideal
but that's what we've traditionally had
um
and it i'll i'll point out to 391 again
because 391 happens to be the best well
the best by
the standard of perfect distribution or
near perfect distribution underneath
that you'll see one more distribute one
more um
this is the average median standard
deviation and largest deviation
so the average remember this is how far
they are from perfect right so this is
all 10 counties collectively how far
away they are
it's not a perfect way of looking at
this because the counties are obviously
not all the same population
but we're trying we've we set that in as
a boundary already so we're kind of
already working every time we you know
set a new standard we're moving farther
away from the perfect ideal right the
three four four three r three four four
four um
so underneath that is the median
if you're going back to your fifth sixth
or seventh grade math class um
that's going to be the um
the number that's the number that if you
line them all up the one that's closest
to the middle
the one that's closest to the middle uh
the standard deviation so the standard
deviation this statistical term it's
basically their distribution so this is
not the standard deviation is not from
zero the standard deviation is from
their average but what the standard
deviation does is it lets you know how
far away they are separated from each
other right so in an ideal world we want
them to all be
equally as off right um
you know um because we're already
dealing with an imperfect world um and
then the largest deviation that one's
not rocket sciences that is which county
has the farthest away from the ideal
so um once again belknap county did me a
huge favor by being the the
bel
and in 400 so if you look at them
they're 0.49834 there's really no other
way to be farther away from zero
than
0.49834
so you'll see they are the largest
deviation um and that changes i don't
have which counties labeled for that um
but that just kind of shows you how far
off so you can look at 400 you can look
at it all the way down to 375. i point
out 391
because it kind of actually is the best
looking you have two other sheets with
you that are not in pretty colors
but all this is is the data broken out
into a line graph and a bar chart
so the the line graph um
is the easiest one to kind of look at
and get a fast assessment of the
distribution by um number and that's
where 391 you can really just look at it
lower is better right we want that
number as close to zero as possible um
so you can see 391 is is very nice but
um
so that is that that is that massive
amounts of sheet in a very very small
print
that you have in front of you and i'm
happy to answer any questions anybody
has about it
thank you representative um for doing
this it's very interesting and
um
i
i'm impressed so thank you
as a lawyer i'm sure the lawyers on the
committee can can agree
we're not as good with numbers um can
you explain to me so for example we're
looking at
a 391 which you you mentioned is the has
the least
i guess deviation from the perfect
proportion
so what is the the benefit of that from
a mapping standpoint
um i i i don't think i can answer that
question from a mapping standpoint um
it's i'm thinking it more of as a as a
representation
inside the i i guess i guess the answer
that would be it would be easier to draw
the maps at that level
um but that doesn't mean that we should
um we've had 400 for quite some time i'm
not advocating that we moved to 391 but
i think the committee needs to look at
very impressive
representative barry
would it be fair to say that what this
might represent
most
closest to perfect allegation of reps
per county
isn't that correct because because we
believe we cannot count cross county
lines because
um the state representatives make up the
county delegation
um
we're already dealing with an imperfect
system right off the bat we're not like
other states or state representative
districts i i'm not aware of another
state where a state representative
cannot cross a county line
i could be mistaken in that so don't
don't hold me to that but i'm not aware
of one but because we operate under that
equal protection one man one vote
principle that's assigned with county
government
we are already operating underneath a i
don't want to say flawed but
representative thank you madam chair
uh representative berry i'm curious
if
going to 300 391 representatives
does it actually make it easier for us
to map within each county
in theory it would um because you would
be dealing with remember because we're
still even when we go into a side of a
county like so with 400 we know it's
three four four four um i think it's
three four four point four four
3.44438 to be somewhat close
um
but so you you would in theory be
getting be a little easier to draw the
maps um because you would be you would
have less deviation from the perfect to
begin with right so you're you're not
starting as far out from zero or in in
reality and remember this is this is to
zero right so i didn't go through and
program it to be 0.05 and negative 0.05
right which i could have done
which you can excuse me you can still do
the math right everything just comes
down 0.05
so um i i guess my assumption would be
that it would i've never i didn't look
at it from that i was just looking at it
from a
you know what is the what is the
representative it is purely a it was
purely for me a a
a statistical study of what is the what
does it look like if we do what is
allowed via the legislative our
constant our excuse me legend
our laws good lord
which is 375-400
thank you madam chair
as i'm i'm remembering from last time
that i come from a county that was
entitled to 23.48
representatives and of course that got
rounded down to 23.
and i will say that it does actually
make a difference when you try and come
to do the mapping because it's all
it's the deviations are already skewed
um
and i remember
coming up with a map that would have
worked really really well if only we
changed dublin and gave it to
hillsborough county and dublin was
about 1500 which was just about half of
one representative
but that didn't happen uh so on a purely
mathematical level i think i think it
would
be better
i
wonder
what
the
response is
from people
for whom this will mean
significant disruption in what they
think of as the status quo and what they
like in the places that they like it i
know that there are places where they
don't like it
uh but i'm
i'm i'm not sure how
the going from
from 3000
it's not something that should make a
difference but it may make a difference
and i don't know what kind of difference
it makes and i i certainly
before we go too far down this road and
start redoing map making software and
things like that i'd sure like an
opportunity to hear from the public
about their thoughts about it i do know
that we had testimony from one member of
the public
who suggested that
would be a better iteration than 400
uh but i don't think he took into
account all the other ones in between so
i i i thank the representative very much
for his comprehensive work
if members want to turn to
representative smith steve smith
thank you madam chair
and thanks for that work ross it is good
to see but i think it's
highlighting the difficulty of the job
we have because i don't think it should
be a goal this committee to provide
people with less representation in the
interests of mathematical efficacy
i'd rather do the the hard work right
now of doing that because if that is
what we cared about you could probably
get really good numbers by going to each
county find a town and municipality
that's within a reasonable deviation a
perfect population give them their own
rep or reps
make the rest of the county one at large
district and be done with it
and i don't think that's what anybody
wants
so
for me
the numbers 400 i don't want to give new
hampshire people less representatives
than that and i'm willing to have my
eyes bleed to try to facilitate it
thank you
um in regards to this issue this has
obviously been an issue that's come
before the house before
you have
in front of you two memos that have been
provided to the committee that will be
placed online in regards to
how has the constitution changed in
regards to this issue to its current
date and how
what if any efforts have been made to
change the numbers
um there is an interesting history that
goes through the 1784 constitution
which actually was intended to fix what
was being done without a
constitution and then there have been
four amendments since then
of
interest probably in line with
what members have said are proposals to
reduce the size of the house quite
frankly i had no idea that there were
this many
attempts to change the number until
staff had put it together
and there have been five ten
fifteen at least twenty proposals
including
four since two thousand to change the
size of representatives
um
so all of them have been defeated by in
the house by a voice vote
um
and
so i i think i probably shared the
sentiments of everybody who has spoken
here
but
once again i think perhaps i thought
something that was good to consider but
i'm not sure it makes sense to implement
it in this
process so
representative turcotte thank you madam
similar to represent
representative steve smith um
i'm not sure the
potential for ease of mapping
which i'll speak to in my second point
would outweigh the changing of the
number uh from 400 down to a
any number less than 400 i think there's
uh the redistricting processes
filled filled with enough land mines
that we don't probably need to add too
many more in there and i think this
would be one of them
having spent
many many many many many many hours and
as you mentioned before
don't anybody do it after about seven or
eight at night because you will be up
all night thinking about it
but um i'm not necessarily sure
that changing the number would actually
make
the mapping of at least in the house of
representatives
any
any simpler
where we're doing it county by
county um
yeah we might have a large deviation say
for belt map in that first square where
it's 0.498
but you're still you can still i believe
map the county with equal deviations
within the county so i'm not so sure
although i do like when you look at 391
i mean the colors the color mapping does
show you that in fact that
on a county basis reps per county
it is
uh
more beneficial i don't think actually
in in terms of mapping individual
counties and that's pretty much all i've
been doing
i'm not so sure that'll make a
difference so i i i would say to
attempt to change the number down from
400 at this point would probably not be
representative steve smith
thank you madam chair it's um worth
noting when you mentioned that
it was defeated in the house through
multiple administrations going back
decades on a voice vote that the only
way that could have happened was that
the motion came to the floor itl
so not only was it defeated
it came out of committee with the
recommendation of an expedient to
legislate on these two pages i counted
19 times
i just want to make it clear that we're
talking about apples and oranges here um
the
uh impressive research about all the
other attempts to change the size of the
house or constitutional amendments that
would
lower the number significantly below the
currently permitted 375 to 400
whereas
what i think we're discussing today is
not a constitutional amendment to lower
the house numbers beyond 375
but to pick a number between 375 and 400
which we're currently allowed to do
i don't think that that necessarily
means it would be any more popular i
just want to point out that
if we're using the constitutional
amendments as a point of reference for
why we should or shouldn't do this it's
not the same animal
thank you representative weber for
pointing out that distinction and just
so the public is aware we're apparently
also defeating moves to either pay us or
remove the hundred dollars at the same
time so it's been quite the history
representative lane
representative marjorie smith
okay
i thank you
very much
madam chair i particularly want to thank
you
for
um
initiating this research um
with the committee researcher i always
get hung up on policy that's what i care
about and i found it fascinating
to read that that history
it occurs to me
that this committee
is facing a series of obstacles
that
we have no real control
over at this point and i would
hope that we might use this conversation
and this
research as an opportunity to open a
discussion that's not going to affect
what we do in terms of our allocation
this time
but might
put in in play
something that could make this system
work to the benefit of all the citizens
of the state so that
i could see us considering
saying that
we should not be limited
by county boundaries
that would make tremendous change in
this state and change that i think might
be for the good but it might not be if
we look at it in terms of changing how
we structure county government so that
we are no longer
the legislative body of the county
government all of that is
fascinating policy
but today it seems to me
that we can't negotiate those changes in
any way that is fair to the citizens of
the state
and
i do like the fact that it's almost
october and this chart shows us
beautiful fall colors
i immediately went to 391 because i
could see
the greens and the yellows
i realized that four out of the ten
counties wouldn't change at all
one would change by three one by
two the rest by one
that is a major
change
and i think we're going to have enough
slings and arrows focused on us
have other reasons to challenge
the appropriateness of what we're doing
and i hope the issue doesn't go away i
hope we pay attention to it it might
require constitutional amendments it
might require legislative change
but not today
uh thank you and again thank you for
this research i would never in a million
years been able to do it on my own
i guess my question is
piggybacks a little bit on represents
smith's which was
what was the purpose when they put in
the 375 to 400 why did they do that and
i don't think these memos really address
that so
you know from my viewpoint what was the
legislative intent of giving that gap if
it's not to consider it in this room
i guess representative lane i can't
remember what the legislative intent was
last year and i wasn't around back then
so i would hate to deem to guess what
the legislative intent was
okay i mean i just wonder if there's a
as follow-up yeah so i'm just wondering
why put it in there if it's not to take
it into consideration when we're sitting
here trying to do redistricting i i
understand your question and i think if
you look at the history of the
amendments you might be able to make an
educated guess but
i i suspect maybe that will be a
question that whoever gets the lsr
proposing a rather significant change in
the number of representatives and
senators will have to grapple with i
think i agree with the statement of many
it's probably not a subject for us to
discuss
any other comments on this
all right well given that we have
complying with the constitutional
guidelines for redistricting
i would ask someone for a motion in
regards to complying with the
constitutional guidelines in regards to
the number of representatives that we
will be using for drawing the maps for
the house of representatives in new
hampshire representative smith
thank you madam chair um i move that for
the purposes of the 2020 redistricting
the house of representatives number be
set at 400.
is there a second second seconds
is there any further
discussion representatives marjorie
smith thank you very much
madam chair
could i ask
why you believe
the motion is necessary
um
since the status quo
is 400
we are functioning within the existing
parameters
why would we need
to
have a motion
on this at this point and i ask that
because there are other
um
points that have been made quite
eloquently i think in the
three
listening sessions that we've been able
to schedule so far where for example
seem to make a lot of sense to pay
attention to school districts and
drawing lines thank you representative
smith for your comments i think that
there's a difference between
constitutional
issues and issues in regards to what
some people might say is pertinent in
discussions regarding
the determination of ward lines
additionally this committee has already
taken votes on certain constitutional
provisions so given that the question
arose in my mind there's an lsr coming
and i suspect this might be a discussion
in the future i bring it forward to the
committee for a vote representative
turcotte thank you madam chair um to
specific specifically to representative
marjorie smith's
comment i think the reason for this is
for those of us who are spending
inordinate amounts of time
doing the mapping
it would be very helpful going forward
to know if we're going to be using the
number 400 the number 375 the number 391
or whatever we have some other issues
coming up later in this meeting that is
similar
to spin wheels
[Music]
attempting to map counties
when you don't know if that's the number
you're going to be using is is a waste
of time so this is a way to nail down a
number so we can actually move forward
with the mapping process for those of us
who are actually doing it
thank you representative steve smith
thank you madam chair i think the motion
is necessary because we're permitted to
do 375 to 400 from a procedural
standpoint i don't want to be a week or
two from the finish line and then have
to consider maps based on another number
but most importantly
um transparency is the word of the day
and we should tell the public straight
up what criteria we're using and that's
why i made the motion
representative barry uh yes madam
chairman um i will be voting to keep the
representation at 400
based
largely on what the committee has said
today and not to
speak for representative marjorie smith
but i believe this is already going to
be a complicated enough process as it is
it already has enough pitfalls in front
of us and points of potential failure
that i think adding another one would be
foolish for the committee
and it will make
life a little more difficult on the
drawing point but i think in terms of
getting maps out that represent the
people um
quickly
that keeping it as it is right now is
probably in the committee's best
interest
thank you is there any further
discussion on the motion representative
weber
i just want to be sure that we're not
foreclosing something that we might find
later on might be useful
am i right in thinking madam chair that
if somebody provides us with a map that
looks really very
good
in terms of all of the parameters that
we've been hearing about from the people
who have come to our listening sessions
and it turned out that that map was at
391 or 375 or a different number
uh could we not then vote to change our
minds and accept that or i mean are our
votes here cast in stone at this point
i think the three-page memo shows that
nothing's cast in stone
procedure is always subject to motions
thank you
representative mcguire representative
mcguire yes thank you
one point is that the more
representatives we have
the smaller the towns that would be
entitled to get their own
and that's something that a lot of
people
devoutly wish
even if and even if it's not possible
because of the
deviations and the size of towns
thank you any further discussion on the
motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
thank you madam chairman
yes representative mcguire
yes
representative turcotte
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes
representative berry yes
representative alexander yes
representative simpson
yes
representative marjorie smith yes
representative bergeron
representative piedra
yes
representative weber yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative griffin
yes
unanimous madam chairman
thank you thank you committee members
the next item on the agenda
um
subject to
the need for further spell check on my
computer
is a discussion on the methodology
to be presented to the committee by
david andrews from open democracy action
um i have asked mr andrews to come here
today mr andrews if you want to come up
to the the table
mr andrews and i are almost on first
first name basis now he has uh been a
trooper and spoken at every public input
session
um by the end of this i i will know what
his favorite color is
and maybe what he likes for lunch
some of us are aware
of something called the mapathon project
which has been working on
maps some of which two of which were
presented at a public input session last
week
and so
in the interest of having a discussion
on the methodology
that we have been seeing every week
i recall that mr andrews gave an
explanation at the first public input
session in merrimack
which supplemented a submission you have
all received by email in regards to the
methodology and i thought that his
explanation was helpful to me i am not
quite as good with numbers as
uh some of us are obviously so i asked
mr andrews to come today and he has
graciously
agreed so uh to come here to talk about
the methodology
um that he's using and uh he has
provided i'm assuming these are from you
on my table um i asked him to bring
things if he wanted to refer to if he
wanted us to refer to him so with that i
i will welcome mr andrews thank you for
coming this morning and adjusting your
schedule yeah thank you for having me um
so
just very quickly uh i've been doing a
lot of different mapping whether it be
congressional down to the new hampshire
house and i understand the the struggles
that you are having especially with the
new hampshire house and the difficulties
of it with the constraints that are that
are that are put forth onto it uh and
one of those constraints is the method
of calculating flow terials
and so
when i had started the process
i was looking at the 2010 maps and i was
i was trying to give more towns their
their own districts and i i was
struggling and struggling and i i
was only able to come up with a few here
there and so
uh what i thought was i thought that
maybe there was a better way
to calculate flow terials
and thus allow for more towns that have
the
uh correct the enough population to have
their own districts um so what i did was
i uh used the
a variation of the current method that
is uh that is done so um first uh
i just wanted to go over a quick history
of the floater because it puts it a
little bit in context so in 2000 um maps
were drawn using what is called the
aggregate method which is what most
people assume floaterials are are are
calculated is it's kind of you take the
extra people from
two different districts and you make a
floaterial out of it if all the
districts
add up to within five percent of the
deviation it's good to go
but in 2002
the maps were challenged in the new
hampshire supreme court in burling v
chandler
and in that ruling
the new hampshire supreme court ruled
that
you could not use the aggregate method
in order to calculate flow terials
because if say
one town gives only a hundred people to
the floaterial and the other town gives
three thousand
it's not very fair to the one person one
vote rule um so what the new hampshire
supreme court said was that you need to
factor in that floaterial deviation
and what they did was they proposed a
method called the component method which
i'll i'll talk about in more detail
so they ruled that the aggregate method
was unconstitutional based on the one
person one vote rule and they proposed
the component method as a as a way that
you could
calculate flow terials but they didn't
rule out anything else so that's kind of
where my method comes in into account
so in 2010
the component method was used this is
the same method that is used in your
program to calculate flow tarials
but in 2010 62 towns that were eligible
for their own district uh were not
allowed mostly because of the
constraints of this
component method
[Music]
so first off i
um
the if you want to look at the it's the
handout with the new hampshire house map
on it and i'm on page
three
which is the aggregate method um
and i kind of explained it already it's
it was ruled unconstitutional so i'm not
gonna get into too much of it but it's
really just the
you add up everybody from the districts
divide by the ideal population and if
that's within um plus or minus five
percent then it's good to go
but
again it doesn't factor in the
floaterial
deviation into its calculation
um so if we go on to the component
method which is the current method
it's a it's a bit of a complex equation
as you can see but in essence what it
does is it weighs
the um the extra people from each
district and then tries to make sure
that those two
populations are are pretty equal
and that's what that kind of uh equation
so i get i give an example on the next
page
so if there's a district with 5 000
people a district with 4 000 people if
you run that through the component
method it comes up with uh
the deviation for the floateral seat as
7.11 for uh district a and negative 7.66
for district b so in this case it would
not be allowed
to to be a floaterial district um
even though
i think intuitively it would make sense
to you know
um
allow for that
um so
what i thought was
um so the one thing that
kind of
the component method doesn't take into
account which my alternative component
method does
is the deviation of the non-floaterial
seats
so
in
being able to
um
factor in the plus or plus or minus five
percent deviation in not only the
floaterial seat but the other
non-floaterial seats as well it allows
for just a little bit of extra
just to
allow for more possibilities in the
mapping process
[Music]
so again you can see in the next example
i use i use the same um
populations for the districts
and with using the
alternative component method um you can
see that it's actually allowed to to be
a
floaterial district in this example
so
it
it does allow for a little bit more
wiggle room in um districting but
it does it it's not as flexible as the
aggregate method is and so you can see
in the next example if we just move 250
people from one district to the other
um
then the alternative component method no
longer works for that so it's not just
as flexible as possible there's there is
some still constraints on it and it
still follows the new hampshire supreme
court's
idea
that the floaterial district deviation
in the uh mapping process
so uh if you look at the the next page
this is the real kind of
important
point of this so i've done
i've drawn maps for all of the different
counties
in new hampshire for the the house and
i'm not saying they're they're the best
ones out there i'm sure that they can be
approved of but i spent
many hours doing this
and um this was the the best that i
could come up with on my own uh so you
can see that just using the regular
component method i had uh
cases where towns that should have their
own
districts were were not able to
seven of which are kind of necessary
one is the fault of my own town
chichester because it's surrounded by
larger towns so it needs to be combined
with somebody so
that's the
that's the case for
for those seven
necessary violations um
so
really so 60 unnecessary violations in
with the component method but you can
see that with the alternative component
method it allows for just that little
bit of extra wiggle room and so i was
able to get it down to 19 unnecessary
violations so only so really 41 extra
towns were able to be given their own
districts
and thus i think follow the constitution
a lot uh a lot better and you can see i
give uh two examples one is merrimack
county
um
you can see that there's uh 10
violations
in
the the above map and then only two
which are both necessary violations um
because of rochester and canterbury and
dunbarton
so it really just allows for that little
bit of extra wiggle room to uh have
districts that
uh
that that i think work better to follow
the new hampshire constitution and then
again uh
hillsboro is the the same kind of case
but it's not perfect so there's uh
i believe 11 in with the component
method
and three
with the alternative component method
which was the best that i could do but
it's still
but i think that this way
would be
a better way to be able to give those
towns their own
districts and thus their own
representatives
so mr andrews this is the methodology
that was used for the maps that were
presented at the public input session on
last it was last week
i i believe so yes
we we had a map of each so we we've done
a map with the component method versus a
map without with the alternative
component method okay and at the public
input sessions we've discussed the fact
that there is
available a website for this committee
that website has links for providing
direct written comment and including
uploading of certain material
i have not looked at it in the last 24
hours i will admit but some maps have
been uploaded so you understand that the
potential is there for the actual input
of maps yes okay
all right and
do you know whether this methodology has
ever been discussed or used before
i believe i am the first person to come
up with it so
okay questions for mr andrews
uh again thank you
could you just clarify a little bit more
about what a necessary
versus an unnecessary violation is just
sure yeah
yeah so in the case of my town of
chichester it's surrounded by pembroke
uh epsom
uh pittsfield and loudoun all of which
are over the 3444
and
therefore all those towns should get
their own
representative and district but since
chichester is too small to have its own
it would need to be combined with one of
those other towns and so the new
hampshire constitution says that towns
shall have their own
district if possible but it shall not
[Music]
interfere with other towns being in one
non-floaterial district
so you couldn't have a
town you couldn't pember couldn't have
its own district and then a floaterial
with just chichester because chichester
would need its own non-floaterial
district which is why pembroke and
chichester are combined into one
district
other questions representative barry
thank you thank you for putting all i
know that you've put a lot of work into
this
it's apparent
it's also apparent to me i should have
labeled this working session algebra you
know 201 because we're way beyond 101.
it makes my excel sheet uh looking
amateurish
um
has there ever been is there any legal
core standing on this has ever been
tried in court anywhere i know we have a
unique system in new hampshire but we
have any sort of legal backing for this
process
i don't believe that this has been uh
brought before any court
the new hampshire supreme court is the
put forth the component method as a
method that would work for calculating
flow terials
but they really emphasize the point that
floaterial deviation should be factored
in so if you go through and read the
burling v chandler it
it emphasizes the fact that the
aggregate method doesn't factor in
floateral deviation at all
and then and then
talks about how you need to factor in
the floateral deviation and the
alternative component method does factor
in floaterial deviation it just also
factors in the deviation of the
non-floaterial districts
representative
turcotte thank you madam chair thank you
for your presentation um
on the sec
can i guess the second to last page of
what we just went over where you have
any necessarily but necessary violations
and unnecessarily
um
i would have liked to seen a column at
the end of that
that kind of outlined the maximum
deviations
because
for my
reading of this i don't know if you've
ever had the opportunity
redistricting law
there's an obvious
i guess what we could call a tension
between u.s constitutional law and new
hampshire constitutional law as
regarding deviations i'm
assuming
that under your alternative
component method that the maximum
deviations even though they're what you
call
necessary unnecessary violations are
reduced that the maximum deviations
what other constitutional law may
prohibit
um so
with all of these i used the plus or
minus five percent deviation which is i
think generally accepted by by courts
around the country as uh
acceptable deviation um
and so
both the component method and the
alternative
component method use that same plus or
minus five percent it's just that
the alternative component method also
factors in the deviation of the
non-floaterial districts and in doing so
other questions representative smith
steve smith
thank you
so i was looking at the hillsborough
maps that you have here
it looks like you create a lot more and
larger fluterials
and then i flip back a page and on
merrimack under your method
that is a big honking flaterial uh
on the top left so is that what happens
to make the math come out right
yeah
just create way bigger districts
it's
so what it kind of does is it reduces
the overall size of the
regular in general
the regular districts but the
floaterials are generally
i'm sorry i'm writing represent
representative weber
thank you madam chair
but isn't it also possible because i'm
looking at my own county and there isn't
a map with it but in my own county
uh what you've stated is that we go to
um
zero
violations
but
as my county stands now
although we don't have huge floateral
districts my own district is four towns
three representatives three towns that
have that should have had their own
representative and to get from one end
to the other you go through the next
state if you want to go quickly
so
i
is it not possible that the large
floaterials versus large underlying
district may be specific county to
county and not necessarily
endemic to this particular program
in
i was just speaking in generality some
do uh
the the the real thing is that you it's
a it's a trade-off in that um you get
larger flow materials but the other
districts are a lot smaller
so the um
it actually allows so
yes you break up uh you give towns that
have the sufficient population their own
districts but then also the smaller
towns can be put together uh more
compactly
and then oh and then you'll you would
have a
overlying floaterial district there but
it does allow for more kind of compact
non-floaterial districts but then larger
kind of floateral districts
representative webber
thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
follow-up so would it be possible for
you to uh perhaps produce and send to us
a comparison
of how many
representatives are in the underlying
district
in your iteration
versus how many representatives
represent floaterials
and perhaps a comparison to that to the
status quo we can always find that in
any case that doesn't matter but i i one
i for myself that chart would be very
helpful
because
large floaterials as we have heard are
not very helpful to people but if the
trade-off were a lot more
smaller in local districts i think that
a lot more people might feel differently
about the large flow tarials and as you
say it's a trade-off but it would be
lovely to see the numbers on that if you
could generate them without too much
mr andrews going to the
the
comparison between the methodology on
uh
your your numerical column page um could
you please tell me what you consider a
violation is and then your ranking of
what a net necessary violation is
yep so just a violation would be
a town that has uh 3444 or over that i
was not that i was not able to give its
own district um and then
i get the necessary violations are just
ones that um
you're you are going to violate the
constitution one way or the other when
you do it either a town
doesn't get its own district that should
or a town doesn't get their doesn't get
thank you other questions
i'm giving people a minute to look
you know
may i sure can i just want to make sure
that i'm understanding what
am i understanding that when you say
that your alternative method takes into
consideration the deviations in the
non-floaterial districts
and my understanding though just to sort
of use simple examples
if let's say that the ideal district was
3 000 as opposed to something more than
just for to make it easy so you would
say if i'm understanding correctly that
well if a town has
let's say a population of 4 000 people
we could we could instead of saying that
the the
the
the population if you will that would be
assigned to the floaterial is one
thousand
we could actually because because a five
percent deviation is allowed
we could say instead of saying that that
the underlying district
that the non-filtering district will
consist of three thousand people we can
make it three thousand minus five
percent
and then
uh
assign that those extra numbers to the
flow tyria
exactly is that exactly correct yeah
yeah that's exactly correct
okay
any other further questions for mr
andrews
every time you tell me about it i think
i understand it and then i think about
it later in the day and i don't
understand it anymore everyone
everyone tells me that
okay
um
mr anders you've also given us another
handout of the project itself which is
not really completely relevant to what
we're here on the agenda for if you want
to submit that online
provisions
button click on the on the website
please go ahead and and then and it's
and that way it will be on there for
information and
you know thank you for providing it to
the committee members
um
any other questions from mr andrews who
i want to thank for coming and arranging
this
i'm sure that you'd be happy to have
people reach out to you if they have
questions on
what you've presented i certainly
really appreciate it and
i look forward to seeing you at a public
input session
okay
so to con continue the math of the day
um we have to deal with representatives
and cities
as we move forward um representative
bergeron has kindly provided us with
another update of the status
so if he just wants to run through that
um but i think we can for purposes of
the discussion we're about to hear
understand that cities are not going to
have things set until
in general
january which will be over a month after
we have a bill to report out of this
committee so representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
um and and i think the chair summarized
pretty much the position that we are in
uh rochester appears to be the only
community the only city in the state
that may have
uh its ward lines done before november
18th they're on track to take a vote on
november 3rd
all the other cities it will occur after
their city elections this fall
some have to go through a charter
amendment process and may or may not
choose to do so i haven't heard yet what
claremont's intent is
some cities like dover and keene are
trying to amend their charter in the
november election to allow them then to
do redistricting by ordinance
if that question fails in one or both of
the cities they then have to start the
whole charter amendment process in order
to redo their lines um
for purposes of redistricting
i mean we could make the assumption that
uh all the cities are going to do it and
they're going to do it correctly and
they'll be a very small deviation when
it's done but it's it's a risky
assumption to make
as we're working with maps some cities
on their own if you will within their
own boundaries for all the reps they
might be entitled to for example concord
uh has ten wards they may be entitled to
uh 13 state representatives they could
theoretically elect one from each ward
and then three city-wide
but it may be that neighboring towns
need to pair up with the ward in concord
in order to make their numbers work
so i i don't have a suggestion or any
thoughts on this other than to say that
the cities are not going to have the
numbers you need uh prior to november
18th
representative weber
thank you i just i just had one quick
question about the city of
oh never mind i'm sorry i i misread the
chart so i don't have a question at all
thank you okay thank you
um yes ma'am shimmering
representative barry um yes the city
warrants from what i've seen um
is that some of these cities are off by
a lot
um i know in my home city you mean with
the current with the current the current
with the current ward lines um i know in
my city of manchester ward 12 which is
our most northwesterly ward
has over 10 000 people now
and there's another ward and it's
escaping me right now has barely over
nine thousand
and that's a massive deviation
it makes it to where when you're drawing
lines
it's actually hard to represent
the wards and the city as a whole
because they're not equal within each
other
one of the wards in manchester would
qualify for its own
while others would be have to be an
afloat
these these cities have to get on this
they have to do this and they need to
draw these lines
as nearly perfect as possible it makes
our job a lot easier when they do that
but they need to they need to get moving
and i don't i don't know but i think we
need to
i i
i want to say thank you to
representative bergeron but
for all of his hard work this is a
massive undertaking um but i i think we
have to we have to let these cities know
that they need to get going
madam chair
representative bergeron um i would just
clarify that a number of the cities were
waiting to the release of the new data
files on september 30th which actually
just came out a few days ago
they wanted to be sure that the
they had software or materials and data
files that they could work with
effectively manchester 10 years ago for
example did their redistricting down to
the neighborhood level you have a series
of
of you have a census track a census
block and and then neighborhood levels
and they were able to keep their range
of deviation within one percent i
believe dover did about the same thing
so they wanted to make sure that the
files they were getting were usable and
they found that the ones that were
released earlier
left a lot to be desired so they
understand their need
it's just that their timelines are
different than ours in terms of data
release
charter amendment processes and
timelines and
and there's just a lot that they're
dealing with as well
representative mcguire
yes thank you madam chair i'd like to
reiterate what representative barry said
looking at concord you can't even assume
one per ward plus three and a float
because the numbers are so bad it the d
some of the awards in
concord are 1500 people
more populous than the smallest award
and that just i mean that
you can't even do a simple-minded
approach
such as one per award plus terena float
it that that blows the deviations right
there
plus as
as i said earlier
you can't just assume concord is 13 reps
and work around it because
that
uh causes problems with a number of the
towns
i think we're going to have to assume
the cities will do their duties
in an appropriate way because
we don't really care where the ward
lines are as long as the populations are
equal and that we know what where where
the contingent
thank you representative mcguire my
understanding is
and i'm not from a city so i guess i'm
going to look to representative bergeron
for this
can it be fair to assume that like a
city like
manchester or merrimack even though
they're undergoing a revision are going
to probably keep the same number of
wards
yes because the number of wards are
determined by their city charters they
would have to
amend the city charter to change the
number of wards
okay
so
there are are there one or two cities
who are thinking about getting rid of
their awards
um
berlin does not have wards okay so
that's the city and i heard that
franklin might also be looking to get
rid of its awards okay so if we
assumed that the cities did the right
thing
our base math should be consistent
even if our lines have changed
i think it's hopeful to assume
that the uh cities will keep their
population deviations within a range of
10 percent as they're doing their
redistricting
the numbers that are currently out there
obviously are skewed i know in nashua
for example the southwestern ward has
had a lot of
residential development so its
population is going to be much higher
than perhaps another part of the city in
terms of increases so that's got to be
corrected
there's also one other thing i would
note i noticed in the case of nashua
that the census tract boundaries did not
adhere to ward lines
so if we're looking at census tract
numbers we can't necessarily assume that
those are true representations of what
the actual population numbers are in the
wards that those tracks sort of fall in
in other words they're overlapping ward
boundaries and the cities will have to
dig down to the
block level or even neighborhood level
to figure out uh where to plus and minus
some of the population numbers
all right representative barry
someone general i want to point out this
is um
this is a a big a big problem for
multiple reasons
the
if we draw our state rep lines based
upon the current lines as they are today
and then the cities go
and redistribute their population
appropriately as they should
our lines will then be out of whack they
will be out of balance
conversely
if they don't redistrict them there's
going to be equal protection arguments
made on the municipal level
if i'm a ward 12 voter in manchester and
my ward lines don't change i'm suing
because i'm being underrepresented in
city hall
so we have to as a committee
come to some sort of consensus or action
as to what to do
with these cities that are so far
deviated from the ideal that it makes it
impossible to do our job we are in a
catch-22 situation right if we draw it
as they are now and they change we draw
on constitutional maps
we have to assume or my opinion we need
to assume that they're going to do their
job in time they're going to keep the
same number of ward lines which as
representative bergeron said i don't
believe anybody has any intention of
changing that
because it's in their charter but we
have to kind of set our course that in
my opinion that they're going to do the
right thing
and if we don't do that we will draw
by default we will draw maps that will
be unconstitutional
thank you and it's kind of a follow-up i
mean i really don't see that the
alternative of using the current ward
lines is an alternative at all because
they do have an obligation to equalize
their wards as soon as the census data
comes out just as everybody else does
so i think that the only way we can
proceed and certainly the way we
proceeded 10 years ago
is to figure out
how many
uh
work on that basis for
you know letting them draw the ward
lines without our looking at the current
numbers because
one of the things we're pretty sure
about is those are gonna those have to
change
um
now
and i'm trying to remember how
oh i know how it happened
what did happen several times last time
is that
one or more awards
given their equal number of population
were combined with a town outside of the
commit city and given
more represented representatives as
the one keen ward that's joined to
the one concord ward that's joined to
hopkinton for example and then has three
for for all of them
and that is not at all ideal for the
cities but
uh i will point out that
all of these arguments are somewhat
circular because it
to combine a city ward with a town that
may have very different interests
it also when we get to the smaller
population
counties and regions just as we've
already heard
it makes no sense to put together some
of the other
groupings that we've put together
but
given that there isn't enough population
to do it another way you wind up
i mean it really is a catch-22 situation
but i
i'm i'm arguing for
trying to figure out the numbers for
each city and then hoping for the best
with that
thank you representative weber i guess
my position would be that we have a
number of wards
and um
we should continue to use the same
number of wards and simply assume
the population per ward and the reason
i'm putting it like that is because i
think that's a programming issue
and i i want the program to be able to
be changed to reflect that assumption
and then if the city lines change the
amendment to the bill that comes out of
this committee is a lot
easier if you're into meets and bounds
because then we can just change it for
the ward lines to the extent they're
specifically in the statutes as compared
to redoing maps because now i have a
different population that throws the
representative weber
as a follow-up to your statement we've
never put the ward lines in yeah as soon
as i said the numbers we've only seen
wards one through seven or one through
three that's the lawyer talking the
judge hoping the judge has his head down
and didn't really hear what you said and
just moved on to your next point
all right anybody else on
on this oh sorry representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair
um
i think there's an assumption here that
the award
the awards are going to largely stay the
same and that the lines would just move
to adjust for population so well i think
the point is some of the awards as they
even existed last time
are so far skewed for equal population
that
there needs to be some change but i
think as representative weber said to me
in a conversation earlier this morning i
think we're all trying to say the same
thing slightly differently but i guess
my point in having this discussion is
that
i need something done because the
program that is out there now
has
doesn't match to anything that we're
talking about right now representative
mcguire
yes thank you regarding your point
representative wilhelm it doesn't matter
whether it's ward 5
exactly that's going adjacent to
hopkinton we know that the city of
concord touches
the town of hopkinton
and
and i'm sure that you know if we say
that the war the westernmost ward
is
is in the district
you know
they probably will make the number the
same but they've got to have a ward that
touches hopkinton there's just no way
representative wilhelm
it so long as it's contiguous right i
mean that's that's the right assumption
that we're making we're not moving the
city boundaries at all so all the towns
that currently touch the city do touch
the city right
representative i'm just is there a
deadline for
cities to do their redistricting well if
you look at the handout the reality is
it's we're not going to be really
getting numbers until january
well and so i wonder
i mean i know that we're trying to get
should we explore the possibility of
waiting until we've got the
the city data back and
the chair would not entertain such a
motion because the issue is is that
we as a body have certain obligations
and we will be voting on things in
january
even if the cities all take care of
everything in january first
which i don't anticipate will be done i
don't know when our first session is to
redo boundaries so the process is this
bill will come forward in the house
and people who have been on this
committee before can add to it but i
know that bills will come that come out
and are voted on by the house in january
we'll be going to the senate so if there
are further amendments or changes that
need to be made both houses will have
both chambers will have an opportunity
representative weber
i'm not remembering precisely but i do
remember that we had this timing issue
before
we did of course get the census numbers
far earlier last time
but i'm
thinking that we may have
even had a rules
suspension with respect to the work
because
the
it would it would it is necessary to
have
all of the data to produce
a proper
uh thing so that might be something one
and i had a further
thought that has now escaped me
um uh
the the other thing to bear in mind is
uh just the issue that we have heard
very clearly from
uh the folks who have come to our
listening sessions so far
that they would very much like an
opportunity to have the same kind of
commentary on maps once maps are issued
and um
if there were to be a rule suspension
that would allow
for more deliberate comment from folks
on actual maps i know all of that's
difficult and i'm just i'm just putting
that out there
representative mcguire yes thank you
madam chair i agree with representative
weber that we do not want to
delay the issuance of maps because the
public has strongly said they want to
comment on them if we as if we
and i'm not willing to give up anything
unless the wards are appropriate so even
if there is a
some some tweaks later we still want to
say okay the cities have been done their
job properly we have equalized wards
this is a plan that we're presenting for
public comment
and and i think that we want to do that
as soon as possible
representative steve smith
thank you madam chair
correct me if i'm wrong i think the
place we're trying to get to
is establishing a policy of how we're
going to do the work because if we
assume that the awards are equalized our
software needs to be updated and we use
the software for two things to create
maps ourselves and to evaluate other
maps that are brought to us
i would not like to have a lot of hours
of work into that
the way it stands now because it does
have the the unequalized wards so
representative weber
and in the past what we did to avoid
well
i don't know who had access to the
software last time around because i
certainly didn't but
my understanding was that what we did
the last time around was we just
left a black hole for the cities
and did not
try and force the current numbers that
we have on the cities into the plan
we just left sort of a black hole for
the cities
which meant that you didn't have to
correct for all of the
all of the data we just we just
allocated x number to the city and and
worked around that until we got to the
very end
representative steve smith
thank you i'm not sure i understand how
that works because in order for you to
do that work
in that way
every city would have to be within an
acceptable deviation a perfect
population and i don't believe that's
true
and i'd like to get to the point where i
can actually finish the county and move
on can you clarify how that worked for
me
all right well all i know that i thought
i was in an algebra class and then i
heard about black holes and now i'm in
astronomy so i think it's almost time
much like my comments on the uh
when we were talking about the numbers
of uh
that we're going to use the 400 uh it's
the same thing as representative steve
smith has just said in order to get
going on our work we need to know those
numbers attempting to draw
these districts
with the wards as unbalanced as they are
i've run into that in several counties
it's just
basically spinning spinning wheels the
other concern i have it's been mentioned
that maybe waiting is uh
you know for the
cities and town or the cities to do
their their work to me waiting is not an
option um
intentionally or
unintentionally having uh
a city or a couple cities delayed the
process that we're trying to get
accomplished to me is not an option so i
think we need to make a decision uh one
way or the other on how we are going to
treat those
cities with wards
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair um i believe representatives smith
weber and turcotte are pretty much all
on the same page and i i would
second with representative weber said uh
10 years ago i was city clerk in nashua
and had conversations with
representative allen court who was
assisting and redistricting back then
and his direction to me was nashua
should just go ahead with its
redistricting process stay within the
range of deviation and the state would
take care of the assignment of uh um
appropriate state rep seats or districts
and
so i think what
i'm hearing most people saying and i
apologize if i'm putting words in their
mouths is that we essentially
say that
city x is going to get so many state
representatives let them do their uh and
make the assumption that if in the case
of nashua we have 90 000 residents nine
wards and that nashville will put 10 000
residents in each of those wards and so
for purposes of our software we just
look at the number of wars the city has
divided by the
number of uh the into the population and
that's the number we put into our
software as being the population for
each of the wards regardless of what it
is actually now that that's the goal for
what it should be after redistricting is
to repeat what representative burgess i
think that's the way we have to go
forward is we have to assume that these
cities are going to do their job i think
we have to assume that they're going to
do a near perfect job i think we have to
as he said take you know in manchester
we have 12 awards 115 000 people 115 000
divided by 12 distribute that over the
different wards put that in the software
and draw our lines based off of that
that would be that would be the process
i think we have to follow i don't see
another path that doesn't end up with us
getting maps tossed out
representative
representative weber
thank you and and to follow up on all of
that and also to circle back to
representative stephen smith's question
we know
if we take the approach that was just
set out
we know what the deviation both in
population and in percentage is in the
allocation made to the city
and we can take into account
that deviation when we're thinking about
what combinations we might want to make
or not want to make outside of the city
just as as
representative wilhelm explained it
doesn't matter exactly where the lot
line is if you know you have one equal
slice of the pie plus a particular
deviation
you can then work out what you do with
it to fix
the numbers overall
okay thank you i think we've sort of
we're actually sort of as a committee
all agreeing that we're all saying the
same thing which i still can't quite
figure out but if we're there we're
there representative mcguire
yes thank you
in full agreement with what's been said
i move that the
the chair direct our
our staff to
assign equal numbers of population to
each ward in each city
so that we can proceed with our mapping
and that we send a letter to the cities
telling that we are assuming they will
do their job
appropriately
is there a second
been seconded by representative turcotte
is there any
further
representative turcotte
yes madam chair i i just like
clarification on uh
rep bergeron's chart where uh regarding
franklin
what are we
assuming
there are we assuming the districts
remain are we
um
because it
could
make a difference all right
so i'd just like to have that clarified
i think we need to treat every city the
same at this time my understanding is
franklin at least from what maybe
representative bergeron can expound on
this is they're requesting they're
leaving their ward lines but they're
requesting to be treated as one
i don't know if that's legal because we
have uh i mean that's my posit my
position is we need to treat every city
the same at this point which is what
legally exists because
we have a standard of political
subdivision and that's a political
subdivision that exists inside the city
of franklin
yes if they if they succeed in
eliminating their award lines that's one
thing but as long as they have them we
have to assume that all three awards
have the same population and that might
require a little more adjustment
afterwards depending on what they're
doing but i think as we proceed
everything at least it's my hope it's
treated the same representative marjorie
smith
thank you very much
madam chair
could you help me
understand how we would handle the
situation
such as
the one that we have in dover and
hopkinton
there's a similar situation i mean
concord and hopkins is a similar
situation with dover and
somersworth
or rollinsford
um
where we have to bring in a town in
order to help make these numbers work
make it more or less difficult
for us to do that
this is not a rhetorical question i
really don't understand
and wonder how that would be handled
representative mcguire yes thank you
it would make such a a process easier
uh rollins ford hat is worth three
quarters of a rep and therefore it needs
to be joined within an
adjacent town it is on
it is actually only adjacent to the two
cities of somersworth and dover so it
needs to be attached to some
section of them and knowing what the
population of the awards are
will make it much easier to do an
appropriate redistricting in that area
representative barry um i just want a
second what representative mcguire says
i just said i take one issue with the
word i don't know if easier or harder is
the right word i think accurate would be
the right word thank you
further discussion on the motion
connection representative glenn i just
asked one question uh there were in if i
understood correctly from the discussion
there are some cities that have
at large they had in other words they
have wards and they also have an
at-large
uh
a ward that consists of an at-large in
other words the whole city is that
correct that might have to do with the
city government representative bergeron
i know that claremont is an example of
that they have four state
representatives currently they have
three wards so they elect uh one from
each of the wards and one city-wide
so it would be an at large and i guess
my only question is how does that what
is the impact of that on what we have to
do that's why you open your program and
figure out where the reps are
representative steve smith
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative lynn for asking that
question because it's the best example
of why this needs to be done
claremont lost a boatload of people out
of ward 3 which created a massive
deviation
between that warden wards 1 and 2.
right now
when you give each of the three wards
its own representative and then create
the city-wide fleterial when they're
equalized the deviation is about 3.3
without doing that the deviation is just
under
plus 10 all by itself
because of the geography of the county
there are necessary deviations that are
negative 3 to negative 5.
so if we don't do this clermont needs to
be ripped up and up the wards combined
with
towns in order to create legal districts
i don't i don't want that and i don't
think anybody does so that's why we need
any further discussion on the motion i'm
seeing none so i'm going to ask the
representative stephen smith
yes
representative carol mcguire
representative turcotte yes
uh representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn yes
representative barry yes
representative alexander yes
representative simpson yes
representative marjorie smith yes
representative bergeron yes
representative lane
representative piedra
representative weber
yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative griffin
yes
unanimous madam chairman thank you thank
you to committee members we will do that
um so what i will be looking for is
for staff to make arrangements for an
updated
programs for you to use
i will ask them about the possibility of
producing something alternative to a
thumb drive i have no idea about the
ability to do that
and you will and what i would like to do
is to have an email sent to you when
they are ready so you can then respond
to let us know whether you want it
mailed or picked or you will be picking
it up because you're here on other
legislative business
we had an instance where thumb drive was
mailed and it didn't get to where it was
supposed to go so
if people are available to pick it up
and would rather do that i want to do
that
we do have county listening sessions
dates set up for all but two counties
tonight needed to be canceled because it
needs to be rescheduled
and the rescheduling is requiring a
location change which we are working on
belknap i believe has been tentatively
scheduled for the 19th but there's some
administrative um things to make sure
that we can secure the location which is
proposed to be the mills
and as soon as that is definite you will
be informed so we will be having
listening sessions through
mid-october which was i think the stated
goal
at the beginning of those sessions
representative
marjorie smith
thank you very much
madam chair and i would like to also
thank you for
having to jump through incredible number
of hoops
to get the 10
listening sessions set up and i know it
wasn't easy and i know the burden for
that fell on the house and i
particularly want to thank you for that
now i mean don't want to get you annoyed
because i really do appreciate all that
you've done but i also
would like us to find a time sooner
rather than later
when we might talk about other factors
that we believe are essential if we are
going to do the best job that we can
possibly do
i alluded to one earlier
that was
based i think on incredibly strong and
persuasive testimony that we heard in
the three counties and that had to do
with
when we moved to combine towns
that we consider
i think the euphemism is communities of
interest
but one in particular to me stood out
and that was school districts
and
i would hope that we might want to uh
and that would be probably high school
districts rather than
you know the local elementary schools
i i hope that we might give some
consideration to including that in our
decision making
and i don't know how you might want to
proceed about that and again i am
serious in thanking you for the
incredible work that you've done
thank you very much for your kind
comments and thank you
to representative smith she is one of
the representatives that has attended
all the public input sessions so far
along with a couple of other members um
so thank you to for that um it is my
hope that we we just had a fairly long
discussion on a pretty a couple of
pretty specific things
um the number of representatives and
allocating population in a city
um it is my hope that if we have
discussions about
non-legislated
parameters for districting that it's
done with the preparation with the
presentation of maps
i will tell you as chair i am not really
particularly well i am i am having
public input sessions to hear input
about things but i think ultimately this
committee needs to get to what its task
is which is looking at maps so what i i
would expect that if people are
particularly concerned about
various factors such as school districts
that i would see that in the
presentation of maps to the committee
for review
by other committee members so
um we'll be scheduling meetings as soon
as i have some sort of a schedule
of course it will be put on the website
and committee members will be informed i
have november 18th at the end of our
agenda because that is indeed the date i
understand is the report out date
so
we will be proceeding on that and i look
forward to everybody's discussion while
we're looking at maps on those other
parameters
that's all i had for today's meeting is
there any other business that people
would like to bring i saw somebody point
across the table so i'm going over here
representative lane
yes thank you at least at the meetings
that i've attended thus far it's
apparent that people want
more meetings once we agree on a map and
should we start
scheduling those or do we wait until we
have a map and then schedule them i
don't know we'll
we'll have to may i'll have to make that
decision because um as you may know from
attending those when i make decisions it
seems like the senate then makes
decisions so um i i need to figure out
that may i follow up sure without
getting the other side of the wall mad
at me these are our hearings that we're
scheduling and if they need them to
schedule their own then i would suggest
politely that they may want to do so i i
understand that but i will also tell
people that we have been at a public
hearing where somebody said insisted
that we should be going to every town
um with a map
so
i say that so we can all keep in mind
we're dealing with a big spectrum of
what people think is fair appropriate
and should go forward what i know needs
to go forward are maps so i'm hoping
we're going to start getting to that
pretty soon i want to thank you all for
coming today i want to thank mr anders
for coming and sticking through the rest
of our meeting after he was on the
agenda
you